[Music]
welcome to the rstudio enterprise
community meetup
i'm rachel dempsey i'm calling in from
boston today
for today's meetup we'll learn how the
team at the children's hospital of
philadelphia
is translating facts into insights
and learn more about a new package for
generating useful talking points
but with that thank you all again so
much for joining us i'd love to turn it
over to our speaker for today jake riley
jake is a data analyst at the children's
hospital of philadelphia and the author
of several r packages related to data
visualization and automated exploratory
analysis
i'll stop my share here and turn it over
to you jake
so hi everyone it's cool to see such a
big people from all over the world
joining the talk today um so yeah my
name is jake raleigh i'm a data analyst
at at the children's hospital of
philadelphia
i love doing data visualization and
geospatial analyses i've also built a
couple of our packages
one is called simple colors that was my
first package which is just nice simple
nicely named colors i'll share a link at
the end down to that vignette um
one around just like working with shiny
dashboards and then headliner which is
the one i'm gonna talk about today
so when i think about
building dashboards i think there's kind
of a spectrum of kind of how the data
can be presented you could have a
dashboard that's really more focused on
facts like the one on the left
versus one that's more focused on
insights so although these two examples
have the same underlying data i think
they have a really different like user
experience so on the left is really just
totals percentages um and i would say
it's really presenting facts whereas the
one that on the right is sharing more
context so that number of 989 total
applicants
like what does that mean is it good is
that bad is that high is it low is it
expected um
on the one on the right like there's a
little more contacts here so it's saying
there's a 10 decrease in candidates
hired and then it's telling more there's
a 20 increase in total applicants and if
that were to continue you know this will
decrease the revenue by eight percent so
the one on the left i think is a little
easier out of the box but because it
doesn't really provide that context i
think there's a risk of of lower
adoption though on the right i think has
more context i find it to be more
meaningful but i think it's much harder
to produce and for that reason i think
it has a high risk of technical debt um
technical debt isn't the term you've
heard of before it's really um you know
if i had to pick this up in six months
or if i had to hand it off to somebody
you know like how much time and energy
is going to be used just trying to like
catch up to speed or to make any like
modifications to it um so yeah i think
the only one on the right is really
interesting but i think it's really hard
to accomplish
so if we look at an example of this plot
so i looked at uh there's a package
called cram logs and it you can say like
how often a package has been downloaded
from crayon um so i just looked at the
tidy verse and
i picked the gigi.2 package and just
plotted the number of downloads by a
month so if we were to make a title for
this chart there's a couple of different
titles we might pick we could say
something like gt plot 2 downloads by
month
straight forward but it's also kind of
static so it's the same title
every time we look at it um
it's not really like providing
like that context or that insight i was
talking about um and because of that
because it's like static and you know
that title always works it's a
relatively low lift well maybe it's
dynamic like you can like pick what
package we're looking at on the
dashboard and all it's going to update
is like that look at youtube.2 we're
looking at player
the next one we could say is something
like ggsplot2 monthly downloads changed
from 1.5 million um and this is looking
by years this is all 2020 versus all of
2021 um so we could say it changed from
1.5 million to 2.1 million so that's
gonna be a little more dynamic um i
would say the insights are like better
but still not i don't quite have a lot
of context um
and it it involves a little more lift so
i have to now kind of create some
aggregations upstream just to figure out
what the the totals are by year and then
like feed that into the title um what i
think is a more interesting title is
something like um gg flat 2 monthly
downloads increased by 44
so 2.1 million versus a prior value of
1.5 million i would say that's like a
very dynamic title uh i think it
provides yeah like more context and i
think has some good insight but it's a
much heavier lift so that that phrase of
like increased first decrease i think
just gets tricky and so i work on a team
of a lot of we have we have a very large
team of our users with with all levels
of experience so someone might be able
to produce a sentence like that with
relatively short amount of code and
someone
might write it in like several hundred
lines of code depending on kind of how
they are trying to deal with the grammar
and syntax um and so
for that reason i i like that title but
i just thought it had this like risk of
really
producing that yeah like a lot of
technical debt um or being hard to
maintain and um
edit over time
so headliner that's this package i built
to kind of help write those dynamic
sentences so
right out of the box if you just get the
main function is headline so we just
pass headline two values we say compare
x to y so here i'm comparing the value
of 32 to the value of 24. just by
default it's going to spit out increase
of 8 32 versus 24. um if i reverse those
numbers i'm saying tell me about 24
comparison to 32 that number is lower so
it's going to just out of the box say
it's a decrease of 80.
so what's going on with the hood is that
headline is our headliner and then this
particular function headline is using
the glue package um and so what i'm able
to do is kind of string together talking
points to create these these phrases so
under the hood of the headline function
is this this function um called compare
values so when i give compare values to
numbers it's going to spit out a list
object with all these different like
what i call talking points so it's going
to say the original y value is 24. the
original x value is 24 the y value is
32. the delta as an absolute value is
eight so i want to say increase of eight
decrease of eight so even if the value
is negative i'm always going to
i'm always going to display it as the
positive so so delta is going to be yeah
that absolute value delta p is the
percentage difference so it's a 25
percent difference um and i've timed
that by 100 so that it's like a um
it's not a fraction but then i also have
some phrases where i'm appending an
article like a or an to the value so on
8 verse 825
um and then i also have the raw delta
value the
delta percentage um i have articles for
both of those uh and then i've also
brought back the sign so
negative one positive one or a zero if
there's no change um and that can be
really useful
in this package if you want to like
color a value box on the shiny dash i
want to show you any app based on if the
value went up or down you could use the
sign to kind of control the color um and
then there's just like the short hand
over ridge values which is going to say
like 20 like
x verse y um and then there's a trend
there's there's this trend value which
in this case is bringing back decrease
so with those talking points you can use
glue to like string them together by
putting them in curly braces so i can
say curly brace trend of curly brace
delta parentheses and then curly brace
original values so when that um when the
headline like reads that string it's
going to put together an increase of
eight with the like this comparison
piece of eight plus comparison
so a little bit about glue um so what
glue does is it embeds arms expressions
and curly braces and then
combines them together to create a
longer string so um an example of using
glue would be to say my age is 37
which it is
and then with glue i can say i am and
then in curly brace say my age and then
it will like find my age in the
environment and then bring that back in
this it's kind of like paste on steroids
um you don't have to like kind of keep
separating with commas and quotes you
can just kind of like string it all
together
using the curly braces to plug in your
variables um and i think it's a very
very cool package
um so we could like try to write these
headlines using just glue so we could
say
um so you can create temporary objects
as you call glue as well so i can say
i'm going to set up x is 24 y is 32 and
then in the curly braces i can give it
an expression to evaluate um
and so this will kind of create that
percentage difference um
and then i can say like x versus y so i
can i can write a sentence that's like
pretty similar to what headlines
spitting out um but headliner just
simple simplifies those steps so i can
just say if i want to write the same
type of sentence i can just say delta p
percent
and then i can call trend so this is
lower so it's going to be a decrease and
then that original value shorthand is
going to bring back that that um like
what the before and after values are
so some examples of like putting these
together in different combinations um so
you can pass it a vector so i passed it
8 through 12 and 12 through 8 so i have
positive negative and also
an example of no change um so when i
pass that to the headline function and i
give it this string to evaluate it's
going to write there was a 33
decrease versus on 18
decrease um if there's no
there's some control you can like tell
it what to write if there's no if
there's no difference at all by default
it says there is no difference um but
you can also like specify what you want
that to say um
and then when the numbers were uh were
higher then it's saying it's 22 percent
increase of 50 increase um
we could uh so increase and decrease are
the default values for trend um so
because they both end in an e we can
just add a d to the end so if i just say
trend
in the curly braces and just add a d i'm
going to get decreased increased um and
then again i'm using that delta p value
to say by 20
um
or i could say it decreased by two and
then show like the raw delta p so
negative twenty percent um or i could
write as a sentence like you know the
difference
and then the curly braces bring back the
raw values that's like negative two so
eight from
um from ten is two less um so difference
is negative two and then i'm writing a
phrase like today equals um the original
x value the prior is the original y
value um so it like kind of creates this
whole sentence for me real i think
relatively easily
so there's a lot of perks of using glue
under the hood um
so as i mentioned earlier you can
you can like make objects as you are
um like calling the function so if i
said a is one and b is two i could write
a sentence calling a and b and then
inside the curly braces add them
together you can do other stuff and have
because headlines using that under the
hood you can actually use a lot of the
same tricks so maybe i want to
capitalize the first letter i could just
create a little function i mean i could
call this whole function which is from
the stringer package which is string to
sentence that's going to capitalize the
first letter um but just for shorthand
i'm just going to write cap equals
call that function and then inside the
curly braces here for the trend argument
which is going to be that decrease
i can say capitalize that add a d to the
n so now we have increased by delta p
with that percentage and then i want to
say as of today and then today i
am just formatting today's date and this
is um like a little shortcut to to build
out a date as like month to year um so
so yeah so you can like build objects
inside like as you call it and then like
string those together
as well um
you can also concatenate them just using
plus the plus operator um so i could say
yeah decrease of one
semicolon
increase of three um you can string them
together like that
uh and then there's a lot of control on
like how this stuff comes back so by
default it's gonna say increase and
decrease but there's a trend phrases
argument that headline takes and you can
use this trend terms function to specify
if the value
um if x is higher than than y
display
in this case i want to display higher if
it's less then i want to display lower
so then when i call this headline of
trend by delta i get lower by two
you can also pass it in named list so
here
in trench phrases i'm passing a list of
higher which is going to be higher
versus lower and then more which is
going to be more and less so then when i
string this together i can call that
higher object that got created and say
higher by
this percentage
and then i want to say two more so the
more um it's getting called from the
trench phrase and the higher is getting
called from this one up here
um so i i tried to make it like pretty
robust so that you can write like a lot
of different types of sentences um and
then there's a similar rule for uh
there's like a similar method to deal
with plurality so if i want to say
something like we hired one person first
we hired two people i can
i can create like this people and
an object upon people and these
employees which it's going to look at
the difference between the two values
and say if the value is is one um then
bring back person otherwise bring back
people um so in the end i'm able to make
phrases like we hired one person this
employee will start monday june 20th or
we hire two people these employees will
start uh monday june 20th um
so yeah we've got our x and y values
these plural phrases i'm using
headline using the methods i described
and then i'm creating an object called
next monday where i'm just figuring out
what the next monday is and formatting
it nicely um yeah and then they just all
get shown together and i get these nice
uh dynamic phrases
there's also some helpers for dealing
with data frames
um
i i created one helper that's just
called add date columns and there's a
there's a built-in function called demo
data which is just going to build a
little data set with um
with with
like some groups and and uh columns to
aggregate on but there's also a date
column so it's really just these first
these first five columns here um
so that's going to come from demo data
but then i can use
i can use add date columns and what
that's going to do is it's going you
tell it what column to look at so add
date columns is going to look at this
demo data set and then look at the date
column and then figure out how far away
that value is from today you can tell it
what date to reference but by default
it's going to like count from today so
it's going to say this is one day ago
this one week ago since sorry
i ran this yesterday so it was uh zero
days zero weeks zero months but if i
pick an earlier date like from february
it's 120 days ago it's 18 weeks ago it's
four months ago one quarter ago same
calendar year same fiscal year um and so
by using this helper function of this
add date columns i can then use this
compare conditions function that is in
headliner to say compare when month is
zero so when it's the current month
versus one month equals negative 12. so
that's going to compare the sales for
this month versus 12 months ago and it's
really using the across function so it's
it's
it's like filtering on a condition
within the data set and then using
across to
um to aggregate it so you can tell it's
like aggregate using means and
standard deviations to sum them to count
the number of values
there's a lot of different uh ways you
could aggregate the data
by default it's going to it's going to
grab the mean
so i just created this u over your
object and it's going to spit back using
compare conditions it's going to
it's going to return a data frame um
with
the it's going to say mean sales of x
and moon sales are y
so
with that data frame i can then pass it
to a function to create a headline
it's currently called headline list i'm
probably going to rename that at some
point um but if i give it a data frame
with one row it will know to
return a headline from that because it's
going to return a string so if i give it
that url your data frame that i just
showed tasks at the headline list it's
going to write for us a decrease of 6
101 versus 107.
if you have many rows which this is a
use case i i use quite often i want to
create a headline for every row in the
data set
you can use add headline column so
there's a built-in data set for
headliner called pixar films um and from
here i'm just going to select the name
of the film it's rotten tomato score and
it's metacritic score and i just want to
compare like which ones is the is the
run tomato score higher than the
metacritic score so by how much
um so i can use add headline column and
this time when i call x and y those are
going to be names of
um columns in my data set so i'm going
to compare
rotten tomatoes to metacritic and then
i'm going to write a headline
um
so when i write the headline this time i
have not only the talking points that i
described earlier but i can also
reference columns in my data so i can
say
film so that's from my data set that's
the title of the film was and then i can
use those talking points like delta
trend etc um to string together
sentences so i've picked uh the trend
terms higher and lower
and so i'll get something like onward
was 27 it's higher monsters include 17
points higher cars 2 is 17 points lower
um just to describe the difference
between the metacritic and the the
rotten tomatoes and the metaphysic
scores
i also can tell it to return columns as
it does that um and i use this quite a
bit to
kind of bring back the most interesting
talking points so i
am able to say
yeah bring back the delta and the raw
delta and then arrange it in descending
order by just the absolute delta value
so when i do that the biggest change is
the biggest difference is with the movie
onward
um
followed by monsters inc and then cars 2
but i can see both the absolute value
and the raw delta showing that it was
like
it's not only a big difference it's a
different positive negative
so in practice i just want to share like
some ways that i use this to create um
to create charts so i use this in
conjunction with the gigi text package
so again
i use the tidy verse downloads off a
crayon and i just wanted to know like
which package had the biggest increase
what package had the lowest change
overall and what package had the biggest
decrease
so i was able to use that add headline
column
saying yeah look look at the package
tell me the trend showing it show it to
me as a percentage and then i wanted it
to like nicely label because the numbers
were quite huge these are in the
millions um so in the skills package
there's this label number formatter um
where i can say
you know giv
give it accuracy like into the um to the
tens unit so it's like 2.1 1.5 um and
then there's this really nice scale cut
argument where you can tell it to um
that's gonna add these it's gonna
abbreviate these as like millions
billions trillions or use k when it's in
the thousands um so yeah so as it's
building that headline i am just
creating this temporary object of ln
which just stands for large number um i
usually have better names when i
implement functions but because the
headline it's like kind of all wrapped
in the curly braces having them as short
as possible i think just makes it easier
to kind of follow
uh follow the logic um yeah so i'm
saying the package trended um this
percentage and then in print so in the
parentheses here
and then um doing a large number format
for the x value and a large number
format for the y value so i get these
nice facet headers um where i'm saying
increase 44.4
just a million percent million increased
by you know these different percentages
and then for the magruder package it it
decreased
then what i did so i added the headline
column i brought back the delta and the
raw delta values and then i
just did a little logic saying um case
when we start at the bottom so case when
the the raw delta was the biggest value
that's going to be the biggest increase
when the raw delta is the smallest value
that's the biggest decrease and then
when it's the min
um
the min delta overall that's that's
going to be the values closest
to zero uh that's the lowest change
overall so then i just i created those
um like categories and then everything
else just the way that case when works
is going to return nas so once i've
built those i can say drop n a and now
it's only going to keep the records
where it was either the lowest change
the biggest increase or the biggest
decrease um
and then i just like piped that through
to gigipot and it built this
this this chart for me um
this chart i'm not going to lie it was a
little bit of work to make but it mostly
was just getting the foreboding correct
and the the headliner part wasn't to me
it wasn't the hardest part the hardest
part was like getting different colors
and different parts of this folding
certain values like um i this is my
first time using gg text and it's an
awesome package but uh but the headline
part was like very fast and easy for me
to
to incorporate
using that pixar films data um so this
one i just told it to compare two
conditions and then facet
facet these charts based on um
uh based on the original columns in
their data set so there was the box
office domestic
box office international the metacritic
and tomato scores and then the runtime
so these are all columns that were in my
data
so what i did here is i pivoted the data
to be long
because that's i think the easiest way
to build a faceted chart like this and
then i said there's there's a column in
the data set around the film order so i
said tell me when the film order is less
than or equal to 10 so that's like our
first film so those are the ones i want
to compare against um and the ones i
want are the more recent films so i'm
comparing yeah how how are more recent
pixar films
doing in comparison to the the first 10
that were released
so i'm able to use compare conditions
the data has been pivoted long um when i
did that i have a column called metric
which are these these different groups
and then um the the value
uh
the thing that's being aggregated is a
field called value so it's gonna it's
gonna
group by these conditions and then grab
the means of those of those values
um
and then i also created a little
like a little lookup table for how i
want these headlines to be presented so
these around the box office are going to
be talking about um usd it's going to
have a format with a dollar sign the
metacritic is really talking about
points and the runtime is going to be
talking about minutes so i just created
a little lookup table to give it um you
know the original title was bo domestic
i wanted to say box office domestic and
title case here
and then i'm giving it the like template
i wanted to use for for the headline so
i just i i created um i like compared
the conditions i left join to this table
here to get the headlines i want to use
and then i like just pass that both
those off to youtube and get this nice
nice chart
um so i want to talk a bit about how we
use this at chop
so this is like one of my favorite uses
of of headliner to date um so the team
built this really nice pdf that's housed
on our studio connect and it updates
every two weeks talking about um
yeah like
the first half of the month and then the
second half of the month that just
passed um and so when the user gets to
this
um gets to this content on r2 connect it
there's like a front page which is
really talking about these are like high
level stories about what's changed in
the data
um and then it will say x talking points
and they'll say more on page two more on
page four um but they're using headliner
to write a lot of to write a lot of
these so it's saying inpatient
test positivity increased so so as folks
are admitted to the hospital we're
constantly testing to see everyone's
covered status
so
it's saying you know the positivity
increased in may comparison to prior
months um the average weekly test
positivity average a certain percentage
since the last update in mid-may um in
comparison to a certain value
earlier in may and then also um the
percentage that it was in march um so
yeah so they're using headliner all over
the place here to just kind of create
the sentences saying here's the value
here's the value in context and then
sometimes also comparing to the value in
march which was meaningful to the team
um and then inpatient census since this
is just the number of beds that are
filled um so that's available and the
events that are filled so we want to
know like what's the average midnight
census for um for the hospital uh and
here we're talking about what it was in
may um so say the average midnight
daily census for may was blank it's a 14
point increase from april's end of month
average daily census of that value and
then it's giving more context saying
this is blank above the budgeted that's
kind of like our expected daily census
of whatever that value was um
and then yeah there's like more talking
points here about like where some of
those increases are from and then it
tells them like we're on page four um so
when the user goes to those pages
there's like nice charts and stuff
describing like they're showing trends
over time and there's often more details
again using using headliner um so an
example on the impatient census
page is it has that talking point that
was on the front page but then there's
some some cool
ways that they said the following trends
increased and the following trends
decreased so they're using some of that
logic to say yeah show me show me things
that um kind of using that raw delta
value that increased a lot decreased a
lot and kind of bubble those up to the
top so what i love about this is that
the format of the dashboard remains
pretty consistent it's like the the
users always know
because we've been using this for i
think years at this point um users
always know where to look to find data
but the data that's displayed um
it's always bubbling up like what's new
since you were last here what's like
most interesting so it's not like
they're kind of scary
skipping over a lot of content because
it's the same every time instead the
contact is the um
like what we're including here is stuff
that's like most interesting newest you
know thing that's got the biggest change
since you last saw the report and for
that reason i think it has a lot of it's
like there's a lot of high engagement
um
so so yeah this is how we this is one
way we've used it at chop um but it's my
favorite use case so i just wanted to
share that with you all um and then the
way that they're using the hood is
they're they're creating a headline so
they have like this month look back
function um that they're using so when
they say the average minute the census
for
one month ago was and then they're
they're using some stuff to like color
to color the values um
and then they're using those talking
points like this is a delta point
trend so that's the increased decrease
since
two months ago um or two months ago end
of month ever since the census of
whatever the original y value was um and
then they're using that plus operator to
string together two headlines so it's
saying write that headline um so that's
gonna look like this and then they're
stringing together a second headline
saying this is
a certain value above the budgeted may
average daily census of whatever that
value is um and then yeah they're here
they wanted to say above and below so
they're using that trend phrases um
argument to specify not increase or
decrease but above and below
so that's kind of an overview of
headliner um i do have some next steps
um it is already on crayon so you can
install it with install packages
headliner um i have a vignette on there
i'll share that
i'll show you that after i stop trying
my screen here um i i do know that
there's an issue with n a values um
someone was like live
uh like trying this out uh in a meetup
and the first thing they did had n a
values and through an error so uh a bug
is fixed i just need to send it off to
cran um i do want to increase language
support so right now that
on 8 verse 8 33 like that a an language
is really specific to english at this
point so i would love this to be
something that folks can use in other
languages as well um i am looking into
the option of setting default values
globally so if you always want that
um
you know i said like x versus y you want
to say
x from y or there's like ways that you
always want certain things to be
formatted you don't want it to default
to increase decrease you always want to
be more and less so i'm looking into a
way to just set those those
values globally kind of the way you
might set a ggplot theme at the top of
the script
and i've also started building out like
a widget to help build headlines so you
can kind of give it two values to play
around with and then you can put your
cursor in this box and click on
different talking points and i'll string
them together show you what it would
look like and give you code that you can
then like copy this into your script um
so that that's the overview of headliner
um i'd love to get any feedback you have
um this is my email address uh there's
an issues page on the github if you find
anything that's not working um
yeah that's
what i i have for you all
awesome thank you so much jay
i always use the reactions down on the
bottom so you can hear us clapping and
see it through our emojis
thank you for a great great talk this is
awesome
but i see jake there were a few
questions that came through already and
one was
can you use every package you want
within your work environment or are
there regulations
what do you mean i'm not sure what that
means
um i'm assuming it means like do you
have access to
crayon or how do you keep track of what
packages you can use
are you talking like at the hospital
like are there regulations yeah
okay um
yeah i think anything that's on crayon
is fair game crane does a really good
job of making sure that there's nothing
um dangerous coming through anything
that's gonna like send confidential
information over the web or um
i think that they do a really good job
of
ensuring that their content is is
safe um so i think for the most part uh
anything on crayon is is
an option and then we have our internal
we have like an internal brand that we
have where we um have in-house packages
that we've built um but uh from what i
can tell yeah everything seems pretty
pretty pretty fair game um we do a lot
of code review as well so if something
is kind of weird in there hopefully
someone in code review will catch it and
say
i'm not sure if we should use this
package um we do really try to encourage
that folks use
um
like our core packages as much not our
our core but like a set of core packages
so anything like the tidy versus fair
game
um but if there's like a package that
does something
just slightly better than something that
tidy verse does i think we would just
recommend to use the tidy burst function
just because a wider portion of the team
is going to know how to interact with
with that package versus something
that's like more niche
i know there's another question that
just came through on the chat which was
how do you load previous data sets to
compare to current data sets
um so if you were to use compare
conditions to try to say
um
yeah some values in a different data set
in this data set and i don't want to
like compare those conditions uh i would
probably row bind them i could create a
column telling me the source of where
that data came from row bind them and
then use that compare conditions to um
to find the difference just comparing
two data frames generally there's a well
i don't think that's what you're asking
the water package is great for comparing
the differences across data frames but
in terms of using something like the
compare conditions
function yeah i would probably row bind
them and then
um
figure out the difference between the
two or you could aggregate them so you
could say like
grab like you could say headline the sum
of it made first data frames column and
then the y value would be the sum of
a column in a different data set and
then
headline will work
with that as well
thank you and what was that package you
said
oh uh waldo but i think that's something
different that's like my data sets are
or uh something change and i don't know
what changed
um
like you're trying to find a data entry
error but waldo waldo is really good for
that auto compare is the function
oh i get it like where's waldo where's
waldo yeah
okay
where is his bug yeah
so there was another anonymous question
that was
when you mentioned a front page on
rstudio connect with the headlines what
is that
uh it's not really a front page it's a
pdf and so it's just the first page that
the users see is
um
has these talking points it's not really
like a different page that these are
seeing um there's ways you could do that
if we were building a dashboard um you
could have like
yeah different pages to navigate through
but it's it's a pdf it's just the first
page of the pdf
that we're using here
sorry that was confusing
uh thank you um i see jacqueline you
asked a question uh let me allow people
to unmute themselves too if you want to
jump in and ask it
hi sure jake this is awesome i wish i
had this when i was working as a data
analyst in a health system
i see a lot of value here um and one of
the things i'm thinking about is all the
you know scientific manuscripts um
and preparing manuscripts and actually
you know as you change one little thing
about you know
you get rid of your outliers and then
you know you're gonna you're gonna run
your results and it's going to change
very slightly but you want to kind of
capture that in the narrative of a
manuscript i see a lot of value for this
is is anyone using it for that at chop
right now or that you know of
method not that i know of but headliner
is pretty
pretty brand new so i haven't been like
in the past you could only get it on my
my github um so i wasn't really
promoting it that much but now that it's
on it it just kind of cram like two
weeks ago um so i am now trying to
spread it so yeah hopefully someone will
start using it for manuscripts at shop
um but it's in my knowledge i don't
think anyone has yet
yeah that'd be a cool um example to get
out there too
yeah i i can see what you're saying yeah
you like make some slight changes in all
the places you said increase you might
not even be talking about decreases or
no significance or something yeah
thanks jake i see someone else put a
question in slido um that was what has
the reception or usage been of this
people really like it um i did get a lot
of feedback i had terrible argument
names when it started so i have worked
with folks um to rename it so
the stuff that's on crayon i feel pretty
good about we workshopped it a lot um
but yeah the reception has been really
positive
um i know a couple i know at least two
teams that that are using it at chop um
and i've used it myself for some of my
projects um but yeah folks folks seem to
like it they find to be pretty versatile
to say a wide range of sentences
so that's what i was hoping for
that's great
a question that i had was how has this
helped kind of change the conversations
that you're having with people across
the hospital
like just giving them the headlines
there like help spark conversation or
ideas
i i wish i could speak to that more i i
didn't build the executive report so i i
haven't been in conversation with the
stakeholders i've just been able to talk
with the analysts who did it and it
sounds like the their teams do really
like the report that they now have but
unfortunately i don't really know how
they're using it but i i i feel that it
is because it's so dynamic and like
bubbling up the most interesting talking
points and um you know kind of keeping
the report fresh i i would guess that it
does have like high engagement and high
value to its end users
cool thank you
um i see one anonymous question was what
has the adoption of r or python been
within the hospital analytics team
yeah we love r um i think we're one of
the bigger our
groups
for our studio if i'm not wrong i mean
we have a humongous team i think we have
almost 100 people
um and almost everyone's using our and
our studio connect um to host our our
assets so uh it's been really positive
we have a lot of folks who come over
from python and they pick up our pretty
quickly um because we're getting more
python people and i know that our studio
is doing a lot of
uh a lot of work to make sure that our
studio can be
a bit language diagnostic so you can
like write stuff in python you can like
mix and match your r and python code
together with particulate um i'd be
curious to know if we start seeing more
python output from our from our team but
uh yeah everyone
everyone has like some comfort with
python or with r and then even our
python folks have adjusted pretty easily
but i would say it's probably like 90
our 10 python at this point
thank you
another anonymous question i see that
came in is
i work at a hospital and my manager is
very leery of r because of technical
debt do you have any suggestions for
convincing her of ours value
set up a meeting with us i and i'd be
happy to help chat we've done that with
another hospital just kind of have a
conversation around why these are why we
find it to be valuable
um
so we also use qlik sense which is a
point-and-click application similar to
tableau
um and while click sense i think can be
a bit of a
an easier
learning curve for folks especially
folks who aren't like data analysts um
because because like our stakeholders on
our teams like some of them are trained
in click sense as well um it has like a
lower learning curve but if you're doing
something that's really repetitive over
and over and over again i feel like that
adds a lot of technical debt just doing
like you know like in all these little
boxes saying like what title is this and
like the aggregations are these and the
labels or whatever and the tooltip has
this um where that is actually like less
technical debt to do that in r because i
can just create a function that does
that and i'm just calling that function
over and over again so i i i could see
feeling like it's uh yeah like now you
have all this code you have to maintain
and like not everyone knows are that
that could be like technical debt but i
think our team is ramped up on our pre
pretty easily and you know we have code
reviewed so that is both you know does
the code make sense but also is the code
like documented well did you name your
variables well and those things together
i think um make the code easier easier
to maintain um so you know if the
person's using
um
yeah like they're trying to do something
that's like more complicated and we know
there's an easier function you know
we'll help like incorporate that so i
think the code review helps with the
technical debt um
but
you know a lot of point and click stuff
i think adds
that and then it's version controlled
too so if you want to say you know i
made this change for my stakeholder they
actually don't like it
they want what we had before i can look
in my version history and go back to
that code and like reinstate it it's
gonna be a lot harder to do something
like that with a totally click sensor
um so i i see the risk of
of um
you know having
if there's not a lot of people who know
r that could feel like more technical
debt but
again we also use like a core set of
packages so like you know everyone is
like well trained on the tidy verse
that's kind of our bread and butter um
everyone's well trained on our internal
r package um that does a lot of our
charts color themes et cetera
and then yeah just like good variable
names and documentation i think does a
lot to reduce
technical debt
and like i said feel free to like
schedule some time with with me we'd be
happy to talk
with you or you know your manager to
figure out what some of the barriers are
that's awesome and i know chris you
shared your
linkedin in there as well so i'll share
it again if they want to reach out
or sorry jay i see chris put a comment
at the same time um
but i also shared a few helpful examples
um of other teams that are using r as
well and i thought a good one to share
as well was from one of our other
healthcare meetups
chris talk on building an r based
analytic practice at children's
wisconsin
and i just put the youtube link there
too
and chris feel free to jump in too if
you want to add anything as well no i
thought yeah jake you did it that was a
great answer um i definitely we use
reproducibility too as a good reason to
try and convince people who are maybe a
little leery of
adopting our just you know when you do
an analysis in excel or like you
mentioned jake tableau or click
sometimes it's hard to reproduce right
or if the data changes or if you come
back and then you get different results
it's much easier to run a script again
and produce the same output with our
thanks chris yeah
we also do a lot to like share code
across projects so um like i said we
have a central r package that does like
we were making a certain kind of chart
called spc chart that kind of says has
our mean shifted um
and we were you know it was like a
really big gt plot call prior to us
putting it in our package and now it's
like just kind of a one-liner so they
make an spc chart using this as the x
this is the y um and aggregate it using
a certain method um and you know just
just having like a
a central
r package to to handle something that
have you know those more complicated um
steps that you're repeating over and
over i think releases technical debt um
and then some folks maybe it's not worth
putting into our central r package but
that specific clinical team
is asking for the same thing over and
over again so they will have all of that
teams projects in one repo and and like
a shared script that people can use for
different dashboards so it's always
going to kind of call the same function
or make the same visual across
dashboards so that's like another way
you can do it as well
awesome
another anonymous question was how does
chop use r for non-clinical analysis
uh i mean
we
at the parking garage we wanted to close
the parking garage for a period of time
we went to figure out like how that
volume would would adjust or i don't
know all the details of the project but
yeah we were just like trying to look at
the parking garage and uh because it
gets it's really congested at certain
times and we needed to close one of them
for a period of time
and yeah we did a lot of analysis
um
which i think the things that aren't
clinical
um
a lot of it's clinical
um
yeah i mean uh the team's also
it's not on my team but there's a whole
research arm of the hospital and they're
they're using it also with the research
questions as well
um
what the parking lot is what i can think
of or we were looking at badging in and
badging out there like a system of like
folks needing to
um yeah kind of like tracking like who's
coming to the hospital especially with
kovid and
everything we were just trying to figure
out yeah like who's coming in and i
think folks were badging and they're not
badging out and we were just trying to
figure out like where that breakdown was
i don't know all the details of it but
anything that uh
requires an analyst usually that
involves r at some point
um
speak one other question i was curious
about you said you have about like a
hundred people that use
are how do you train
new people to use r or are most people
coming in with our background
uh
we do have a lot of people coming in
knowing r already um but we have a
pretty
intense five week onboarding period that
we do so folks learn
not only r but um sql connecting to our
database how our database is structured
using teasa which is that we use for
flavor than like a sql server or other
database um so we teach them
how to connect with the database
give them like help them ramp up their
subject matter expertise so
okay now you work with radiology what do
you need to know you know we like kind
of try to help folks learn how to
navigate the data so not only the
connections data but like what tables
and stuff they might need um and then we
have
uh like a two-part
r onboarding that we do so the first is
we have um our markdown template that we
that's included in our package
or our internal package um
and so we open up that document and kind
of walk through
like what that document's doing and
explain okay well this stuff is like
connecting to the database running your
query and just connecting all in one
step and if you need to adjust like you
know you want lowercase titles you can
adjust it this way um so we kind of walk
them through the different steps that
it's doing it goes over we actually
think of the data
loading the packages connecting to the
database
aggregating the data
making a chart and then i think we spit
out like a gt table or something um so
it just kind of goes through these
different steps um so that's like our
our first part and then we
have them
[Music]
kind of build their build their own
dashboard um i'm trying to think we also
have like a flex dashboard
example as well and so
i i think like we're just trying to bump
everyone up a step so if someone came in
and didn't know r at all we're not
trying to say like now learn flex
dashboard which is what we primarily use
instead of chinese so we're not saying
like all right you don't know our at all
like now learn you know some of these
shiny concepts reflex dashboard we just
want them to like get some comfort so so
it's like if you came in knowing nothing
like we just want you to like understand
what our markdown is and kind of how to
interact with it you came in already
knowing r or you know our markdown well
okay this is how we like build
dashboards and we want them to kind of
like we just want everyone like bump up
the stuff it's kind of our approach
but it's it's two sessions that we do
with the group
great thank you
i see two more questions that are left
and one was a follow-up to a previous
question about
comparing past data sets what they're
asking is if this analysis is running on
a weekly basis
how do you compare last week's analysis
to this week's
maybe some people
yeah
i don't
currently see a process where we're like
capturing that data and then
like carrying it forward um
i think in the slides that i showed we
have like
something that's doing like a month back
of n so
um i think that number just kind of
keeps looking back one month and two
months and comparing it so hopefully the
numbers are staying consistent from
report to report um but we aren't really
like holding on to the value from last
time and bringing it forward we're just
um
yeah like filtering for
values that were
two weeks ago versus that used
but you certainly could so there's like
the talking points so that compare about
so a headliner like returns the headline
but compare values returns a list of the
values so there you you could be doing
that you could use pins or something um
all those different ways you could do it
but one way you could do it is to use
pins on our studio connect and figure
out the talking points today
pin them
figure out the talking points next time
you run them and like compare the pins
there's ways you could do that um
so those talking points of like the
delta delta p
uh
et cetera
definitely something else i just thought
of and
not an expert at this but i know on
connect you could see like past runs of
something too so if it was like
scheduled
maybe they could go back oh absolutely
yep
there's the logs
um one last question that came through
on slido was so is your team embedded
within a centralized analytics team for
the hospital yeah yeah we we have a
central team and then we partner with
different clinical groups so
um there's a qi version or a qi portion
of the hospital
maybe the success department will say
you know we want to decrease
length of stay or triage time or you
know they have like some goal that they
have um that they think will improve
patient care
patient experience um
so that would be like a quality
improvement
um project that they would be working on
um so we have like teams devoted to that
and then we have um analysts who are
like partnered with like urology
orthopedics radiology etc um so they're
like dedicated to that team but they sit
within
our central group
um so the managers are all managers of
analysts um
and then yeah there's like someone
closely
on that clinical team that like we'll
partner with uh with us so like i had a
person ortho who was kind of
intermediary between
clinicians needed she's a
bioinformaticist so what the clinicians
are trying to do and what i need for to
answer their questions she would kind of
like help bridge that gap so i worked
really closely with her to yeah when i
was working
i know i said one last question before
but there's one more
were there any major challenges in
creating the hospital's internal package
i think just time like giving dedicated
time for people to work on it i think
that the um
we're very busy uh we've spent a lot of
time like getting the hospital invested
and having an analytics team so we just
can grow and grow and grow and growing
so there's like
even though we're a large team there's
still just so much work for us to do so
i think the biggest barrier has just
been dedicated time to work on our
package i think that the team has
recognized the value that it brings but
it's been hard to like carve out
time to work on it so because it's like
well i really want to work on that but i
have all this other stuff on my plate
like i kind of feel guilty working on it
um so just really like working with
leadership to say like no no it's like
really worth everyone's best interest or
it's like for everyone's best interest
would be like make a little time for us
because it's going to save so much work
down the road
absolutely
also like we had to learn how to do
package development you know it was like
new for i think all of us
um but that's like where i learned how
to build packages headliner would have
never happened if i didn't work with our
um
our central group so there was already
an r package
that was
that had been built when i joined and
then i just started like working with
them and i learned a lot there
but that's a little bit of a of a
barrier is learning package development
but there's great resources online for
that
did you use hadley's book or what in
jenny's book or what was it oh yeah yeah
absolutely yeah the r dash tkgs our
packages that
the book down site is great
perfect
into the chat too okay awesome thanks
well
thank you so much jake for for sharing
your experience and and sharing
headliner with us that was awesome yeah
thank you for letting me present um
please reach out to me i love to hear um
yeah how folks are using things places
where folks are stuck um
okay thank you so much jake
really appreciate it
thank you all for joining in for all the
great questions too
have a great rest of the day everybody
[Music]
you